through largely deserted early-morning
streets in South London dozens of police
vehicles on route 2 launched this major
operation parked up in residential
neighborhoods these territorial support
group officers meet the final part of
their journey on foot so as not to alert
their targets so-called high harm
individuals involved in dealing Class A
drugs like cocaine and heroin police say
those they are targeting are involved in
a lucrative trade that often leads to
turf wars and is responsible for fueling
much of the recent upsurge in knife
crime the mayor's office has provided
extra funding for this nine-month long
operation hundreds of properties waited
more than 200 individuals arrested many
of those with a history of violence
at another nearby property another rude
awakening for more suspects across these
reads officers recovered drugs and money
including 300 wraps of crack cocaine and
one property and more than eight
thousand in cash at another from
organized crime groups in Lambeth and
Civic to single strand sellers on our
streets they all have one commonality
that is drugs and that is the financing
of that drugs so some days their
relationships are fluid they are friends
the next day their archenemies but
subsequently to that violence has played
out on our streets and more importantly
for our communities it's the fear of our
violence with more arrests to add to a
growing tire of hundreds of suspected
gang members police say this nine month
long operation has been incredibly
successful but for every suspect they
take off the streets there are plenty of
others waiting to fill their shoes mark
white Sky News South London